hello everyone and welcome to the second
day of the ancient u.s rapid knockouts
it is also the final day of the
tournament so either we will have
everything solved now in in the next
four games or they will have to go into
tie breaks which means two blitz games
and then if that ends in the draw we're
gonna have the armageddon
so that being said let's check it out
and also if you
if you missed yesterday's match magnus
started by winning two games then in the
third game uh he uh well committed a
mouse slip which resulted in artemis
very nicely winning the game and in the
fourth game magnus clinched to a draw
which means that he wins the first match
and now of course uh he only needs a
draw in the second match to be to be the
victor uh so we'll see what happens will
it be over in the second match or we
will we have tie breaks so it's a really
an outstanding game uh let's check it
out magnus with the white pieces opens
with uh d4 we have d five by our team
you have c4 e6 knight to f3 and the
knight to f6 so the queen's gambit
declined is on the board we have knight
to c3 and now knight b to d7 uh going
for this barman variation of the three
knights of the queen's gambit declined c
captures on d5e captures and now queen
to c2 uh gaining some control over this
diagonal
over this diagonal uh in the future will
also have support for e4 you will be
controlling the f5 square if maybe the
light square bishop wants to be
developed to f5 so always a useful move
we have c6 by magnus strengthening this
uh by artemis strengthening the d5 pawn
and bishop to g5 now continuing
development magnus is obviously castling
queen side we have bishop to e7 and now
e3 uh e3 we have knights the h5 rtm if
not wants to trade off those dark square
bishops so bishop captures queen
captures and now a queen side castle by
magnus we have knights to b6 uh and now
bishop to d3 so just continuing
development bishop to g for now uh and
now king to b1 getting the queen uh away
from this uh c file as at some point c5
c captures d4 might be played and uh
well you know the white king might feel
very uncomfortable there
uh so we have g6 uh saying that all
right i'll probably not be castling king
side because there are already two too
many weaknesses once i get rid of the
pieces here it's going to be very easy
to open up this position with the queen
and bishop already eyeing that g6 pawn
so here there are some games where rook
the c1 was played
uh also bishop to e2 is another move but
the move that magnus plays is h3 it's a
new move so already as of move 13 we
have a completely new game uh artemiev
uh reacts by capturing the knight here
which sure kinda ruins a white spawn
structure on the king side but on the
other hand you gain more control of the
center and you will have very nice
support for e4 if you ever wish to push
it
artemis also castles king side and now
queen to b3 now magnus wants to play a4
a5 uh and try and get all the way to a6
and try and do some damage here so king
to b8 again a nice move getting the king
away from the c file and the magnet
starts pushing his a pawn so a fa a4
we have queen to e6 uh and now a5 now
the queen also guards the c4 square so
knights to c4 and now a6 by magnus
threatening queen captures on b7
checkmate but artemis of course just
plays b6 uh we have knights to a4 now
with some ideas of maybe sacrificing the
knight here at some point if this knight
ever moves uh but artemis says for the
moment it's not a problem rook the c8
and you will not be in time for anything
like that because if you eliminate the
knight d captures on c4 attacks your
queen so you really don't have anything
here queen before you're going to play
king day 8 and there is no actual attack
here
so after look to see it we have kinked
the a1 a nice second prophylactic move
by magnus and now king to a8 activity
also gets his king away from the from
the b file
and now we have rook to c1 by magnus and
the position is roughly equal although
you know for for engine standards but
for for humans uh it's uh it's a
completely crazy position and also
magnus has 11 minutes on the clock
whereas
again a little bit down on the clock he
has some six minutes uh so here we have
rook to c7 not really worried about
anything uh like captures and captures
even though the knight is attacked three
times the problem is you can't really
capitalize on this because if you try
something like bishop capture spawn
captures uh you can't capture this
there's no no no capturing this captures
captures and captures v5 wins the
material for black so instead magnus
just goes back knights the c3
and now rook h the c8 artemiev doubles
up on the c file and now uh it's very
hard to decide how to continue this uh
this game for why do you play some like
rook c2 then double up on the c file
maybe e4 is an idea in some lines but
magnus plays h4 and it's interesting
that this is the strongest move
recommended by the engine so as the
title suggests that magnus agrees with
the engine and magnus actually plays h4
uh now you will be able to lift your
rook if needed probably the idea is
still rook c2 to c1 but at least the
pawn will not be a target here as you
know it's kind of useful uh having it
preventing those black pawns on the
king's side uh from marching forward
uh so knight to f6 by artemyev and now
rook the c2 magnus is also preparing to
double up rooks on the c file knight to
d6 now and here rook h the c1 so still
waiting with that e4 push
and artemium says all right you had your
chances to push pawns now i'm going to
start pushing my pawns and here arteme
just wants to get everything threaded
traded off of the c file and get rid of
those rooks so here knight to b5 this
square has now been vacated so magnus of
course uses it knight captures on b5
bishop captures on b5 and now
you could close the position completely
with c4 and that pretty much ends the
attack but uh
that leaves you open for an undermining
move like e4 in the future making c for
uh uh very weak so instead artemia just
plays queen to d6 adds another defender
here and now magnus again he can always
play e4 it's a it's a very nice idea but
he plays queen to a3 now the pawn cannot
capture as the queen would hang here so
king back to b8 by timmy if he wants to
get his king away from this uh
well basically away from the light
squares and the kink the b1 by magnus we
have queen to e7 now the pawn can
capture the queen here is nicely
protected by the rook and now rook to c3
by magnus playing waiting moves uh each
player wants the other player to make
the first capture and now artemis plays
knight to g8 it doesn't seem to be
uh
well it could could be a waiting move
but maybe artemium knows that magnus
will just trade everything and then
later on you can play some like knight
here and then maybe bring the knight to
c6 or or just be closer to the center or
maybe it's just a waning move it's hard
to say as this is a rapid game and our
teammate is already uh
below two minutes so here we uh start
capturing we have d captures in c5 rook
captures on c5 we have rook captures on
c5 rook captures and now rook captures
artemia captures with the queen and now
magnus says all right you're almost down
to one minute i have some six minutes on
the clock i don't want to trade queens
and allow a position like this to happen
uh because well there's no reason to do
that i will play queen to a4 keep the
queens on the board and now it's already
looking uh very dangerous if black is
not careful and magnus gets a few moves
in with the queen the pawn guarding this
square let's say queen gets here could
be very uncomfortable for the black king
but the white king also has to be very
careful doesn't have a lot of pawns
regarding it
so queen back to d6 bartamia and now a
very quick centralizing move by magnus
queen to d4 from here the queen controls
a lot of squares and
ideas like queen g7 queen to h8 will be
possible later on so artemis prevents
this he plays f6 uh and now magnus uh
continues uh his rush on the on the king
side with h5 uh you might think you
could win a pawn here with a move like
e4 because the pawn is pinned uh for
example 97 and now bishop c4 seems like
yes you're winning the pawn but it
doesn't matter queen to c5 and the black
is very happy uh you will win a pawn but
only temporarily captures on d5 let's
say but now king c7 and after you start
bringing your king into the game king
comes here and now you can't really keep
on uh you know
keep that pawn
and the a7 pawn is on a dark square so
your light square bishop will not be
very useful here so instead after f6
magnus plays h5 he wants to further
create weaknesses here on the king side
and you don't really gain anything by
capturing magnus only wants to play
sound like queen to h4 and put a lot of
pressure on these spawns later on you
can uh move the queen uh let's see you
could go here you could go here control
a lot of these squares so black only
ruins his position and gains really
nothing so instead after h5 we have
knight to e7 uh trying to reactivate his
knight magnus captures on g6 we have h
captures and now as the h file opened up
now magnus brings the queen to h4 now he
will try to well attack the the black
king from behind with moves like queen h
it's checking the queen to d8 uh e8 and
so on so king to c7 artemis brings his
king to a bit of a safer square now
queen to h8 and now uh artemia tries
queen to b4
attacking the the bishop here and while
magnus could simply capture on f6
because if the queen captures the bishop
then uh magnus could capture the knight
uh which you know would be good for him
he decides to keep the tension uh he
doesn't want to trade any pieces and go
into a queen's endgame being up only one
pawn because that's never a sure thing
so queen to e8 now threatening queen to
d7 check followed by queen to b7
checkmate uh and now artemiev has to
play queen to d6 and well try and hold
on to this position but artemis played
king to d6 he uh started getting very
active with his king and now
it's a problem queen d7 check and if you
go to c5 uh it's well it seems like you
could lose a knight here but then king
captures on b5 and you're fine problem
is that white has bishop to a4 and now
there is really no defense your knight
is hanging and if you try moving it then
you're getting checkmated here by by
move like queen to c6 so artemis goes
the other way king to e5 but now just
bishop back to d3 so what can you play
here the queen cannot move the knight
hangs the a7 pawn will fall and you well
you could start by giving off some
checks artemia first starts with f5 but
now just queen captures on a7 and now
queen to e1 with check not an easy
position for artemia as not only is it
lost he's uh down to some 10 seconds on
the clock so king to c2 and now you
could capture here but you don't really
gain anything just king b3 and
everything is still hanging here for
black nothing good can come from this so
after king to c2 we have queen to b4 now
defending the knight on e7 but now queen
to c7 check king of six and now magnus
has to make sure that a7 can be played
uh he checks everything and finally
pushes a7
uh we have queen to a for check
attacking the king king to d2 and now
knight to c6 attacking the the pawn
twice uh but now just queen captures on
b6 spinning the knight the king is here
on f6 so king the g5 but now a lot of
moves are winning but there is one
that's uh you know just uh
completely crushing so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
idea while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding any of
the winning moves f4 is winning with
check bishop the c2 is winning this is
what magnus played but to those of you
who found bishop to a6 this is the
quickest way to win and congratulations
to you for your great achievement
because now we cut off the queen's
defense of the a8 square and next move
we're just bringing another queen into
the game there's nothing black can do
about this so here we will probably see
resignation uh but the move magnus
played is also very strong bishop to c2
artemis now doesn't have a good move you
can't keep an eye on the knight here so
you might as well capture an a7 he
played queen captures on a7 now magnus
captured the knight there is uh of
course nothing better and it was in this
position animal 50 that vladislav artemy
resigned the game uh because he's not
only down upon he's also down a piece so
uh
the second match of the finals again
doesn't go well for our team if magnus
starts by winning a game and now artemia
will first have to win one game and then
get another win to win the second match
to even force tie breaks but you know
it's still early in the match we'll see
what happens maybe artemis can bounce
back uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
christopher alexander sopacakedefy.com
vincent natalie rory o'connor and david
kimura for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals uh
until it ends uh thank you i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your sunday